[Music]
[Applause]
warrren sharp from sharp football
analysis.com also Sports Grid in the
ringer and had a uh great article Deep
dive on what's going on with scoring in
the NFL I was surprised at this Warren
that it's right in front of us but maybe
we're not noticing what's the issue with
scoring and why is it down in the NFL
it's made the games a little bit more
difficult to watch it definitely feels
different than prior years and that's
you know your eyes aren't deceiving you
in 2020 2021 two years ago we were
seeing over 500 touchdowns scored
throughout the league by this point in
the season we haven't even eclipsed
397 this year you know not even 400 um
and this been the lowest average total
score between the both teams combined
since before we had passing rules
changes in the 2010 season where they
started protecting quarterbacks more
started protecting receivers going over
the middle tried to start reducing
concussions from that point onward we
saw saw more
passing passing leads to bigger gains
bigger gains leads to quicker drives
down the field and we saw scoring
increase and it continued to do that we
saw records being set down you know all
these quarterbacks breaking this record
breaking that record and the league
loved that kind of stuff the leag league
loved uh higher scoring and and more
points and more touchdowns this year all
of that's massively reverted and the the
the most interesting thing in terms of
like how do we scale this how do we
explain this in a way that a lot of
people could understand would be that
odds makers in the betting markets try
to set the combined total score between
both teams they try to set the total is
what it's called on the game and this
year that total that they have set they
have seen the regression in these
offenses they've seen the lack of
scoring they have set that average
combined point total between both of the
teams at only 44.1 points that's the
lowest projected total since 2011 so
they're saying we don't think you guys
can even meet levels a couple years ago
5 years ago 10 years ago back to 2011
that's all you guys are capable of doing
and despite the fact that that total is
set so low we are seeing average total
games go under at a
61.5% clip which is the lowest we have
seen or the highest rate of unders we
have seen since 1991 so they're like we
have low expectations you guys can't
score points and we are continuing to
see games go under at the highest rate
and so it's a problem defenses have made
changes offenses have made adjustments
and they're not doing them quickly
enough and the league itself is calling
penalties in a way that they haven't
been before and all three of those
elements are contributing to these low
totals okay how alarming should this be
for the NFS home
office well I think in an era that
they're trying to grow the league
they're trying to spread the game
internationally uh a lot of the focus
has been on these touchdowns for fantasy
football and that certainly has helped
grow the league sports betting is
getting legalized and and here's one
element that I don't think a lot of
people are discussing I didn't hit on
this in the article Dan but I do think
it's a small factor here think about
this when you have games that only see
let's pretend let's use use uh just idea
let's pretend you have only two
touchdowns and a couple of field goals
scored in a game if you have one bad
call from a referee that then results in
a team getting first and goal on a pass
interference call and they score a
touchdown to give that that team a a
second touchdown the third touchdown of
the game that touchdown might have a
massive weight on the outcome of the
game whereas if there's like six or
seven touchdowns being scored in a game
one factors in a lot less and so these
bad calls that some of the refs are
having they get mag
uh they get magnified a ton now because
Point totals are down so the league may
not come out and say well this is a
problem but I do think behind the scenes
that they probably aren't very excited
about the direction of offenses and
defenses catching up to them uh and they
would like to see more touchdowns being
scored they would not like to see the
focus being on their officials uh as
much as it currently is right now but so
what are defenses doing
differently so they're playing a lot
more zone defense which means they're
sitting back which means offenses then
they can't throw the ball as deep down
the field so offenses have said we need
to matriculate the ball down the field a
little bit more we need to throw the
ball shorter and we've seen that the
average Target of depth the distance
that quarterbacks are throwing the ball
on average has decreased over the last
few years ordinarily you say okay we'll
build around that we'll figure out a way
to still matriculate the ball down the
field with these shorter passes because
shorter passes should be easier to
complete than a deeper pass but the
reality is offenses haven't taken that
next step and we are seeing completion
rates that are at or worse than what
we've seen when teams were throwing the
ball deeper down the field so while
defenses are playing more Zone
completion rates have also fallen off
which doesn't make a lot of sense and
the onus then is on the offensive staff
and coaches to figure out a way to
increase the completion rate because the
passes are being thrown shorter in
addition we are seeing something else
that doesn't make a whole lot of sense
and that is a higher sack rate we are
seeing sacks at a 7.1% clip the highest
that we've seen in the history of the
True Media database which goes all the
way back to 2000 but we are seeing teams
Blitz less frequently defenses are
sitting back in zone and they aren't
sending blitzes as much so how are we
getting sacked more when teams are
blitzing less that also doesn't make a
lot of sense as to why that should be
occurring and part of it I think is the
way that the league is officiating
penalties of late over the last year or
two has definitely helped defensive
lines and we can dive in a little bit
deeper there if you want but that's a
couple of things that defenses are doing
differently that offenses have yet to
adjust quickly enough uh to help them
move the ball down the field a little
bit more efficiently and it feels like
at least through the first you know
month and a half the officials are
letting the linemen line up a little bit
further back almost to say you guys need
a little bit of help against these Edge
rushers uh you would think that that
would negate maybe you know that that uh
Advantage The Edge rusher might have and
help these offenses if the NFL ask you
for a rule change to help with more
scoring what would you say well first of
all they they have they have I think
you're talking about how the tackles are
allowed to sit back a little bit more
especially in the spotlight has been the
Kansas City Chiefs tackle but what
they've been doing over the last year is
they've been false false start penalties
by offensive linemen are on the rise
actually and defensive line penalties
such as offsides and neutral zone
infractions are decreasing and so it's
giving the benefit of the doubt to
defensive lines to get some of that
pressure on quarterbacks on offensive
lines we're also seeing just worse
offensive line play around the NFL to
some extent and that's allowing these
quarterbacks to get sacked a little bit
more one of the penalty emphasis that
they introduced that I would like to get
out of the out of the league a little
bit more is the ineligible man downfield
now they never officially came out you
know in the offseason they usually say
okay we're going to emphasize these
rules a little bit more they didn't do
that nor did they change the rules but
just like three four five years ago we
were seeing ineligible man downfield
penalties we're only seeing about four
to five of those called through week six
which is where we are at in the season
in total like less than one per week
ineligible man downfield penalties last
year through week six we saw 39 and this
year we saw 24 over five times more and
what they tried to do is introduce these
ineligible man downfield penalties to
take away the advantage of these read p
uh run pass options the quarterbacks
would stick the ball into the running
back's belly pull it out and throw the
ball offensive lineman might slip a
little bit downfield to help block on
these pass plays they wanted to get that
out of the game but what we are seeing
instead is that they're calling and
flagging these offensive linemen for
drifting even a yard or two Beyond this
imaginary line and it's negating like 30
to 40 yard gains by offenses on just
deep passes down the field that don't
have anything to do with run pass option
plays they're just being very meticulous
about trying to call these types of
penalties and I think that penalty going
lower back to what we were seeing
previously would not negate some of
those penalties and the other thing that
we are seeing is you know defensive
cornerbacks and and and secondary
players in general safeties are getting
away with a little bit more grabbing and
tugging the refs are trying to reduce
overall penalties they're trying to
reduce the amount of defensive pass
interference calls but it's definitely
hurting the product we aren't seeing
quite as many big explosive plays and
the only way you're going to get big
explosive plays if you get some of these
receivers a little bit more open down
the field and so if the NFL wants to
increase scoring a little bit faster
they could allow for bigger explosive
plays and the only way you can do that
is to reduce some of that they they've
reverted from what they've done a few
years ago previously they were calling
defensive pass interference clean but
now what they've tried to do is reduce
the amount of defensive pass
interference which are spot fouls and
instead call illegal contact or
defensive holding which are only five
yard penalties they give the offense a
first down but they don't give the
offense the 20 or 30 or 40 yard gains
down the field so defensive backs are
grabbing and tugging a lot more knowing
it's just a 5 yard penalty that they
might get as opposed to giving up you
know a a 30 or 40 yard uh gain and so
it's to their advantage to do that
they've adjusted themselves and they're
coaching to grab a little bit more down
the field and and here's one other stat
on that same element we are only seeing
48.3% of drives either reach the red
zone or score touchdowns before then
that's the lowest rate we've seen since
2000 so teams aren't even getting into
the Red Zone offenses aren't figuring
out ways to get down the field it's in
large part because this explosive play
rate is down so much great stuff thank
you Warren we appreciate your time thank
you that's uh Warren sharp from sharp
football analysis.com sports Grid in the
ringer